[Música]
y hace un par de años soy dirigente
estudiantil esta experiencia me lleva a
conocer realidades completamente
diferentes en todo
territorio nacional
y a continuación quiero hablarles de una
problemática muy importante una
problemática muchas veces invisibilizada
no sólo en nuestro país sino también en
el mundo entero
es una problemática café
de qué problemática estar hablando estoy
hablando de
bueno algunos siempre
colocación y el desempeño
se relacionan mucho
diagnóstico y quiero que la mujer
alguna vez han sentido
solo por el hecho de ser mujer
o simplemente
si bien está solo
bueno ahora me dirijo a los valores a
cuantos que ustedes acá le dijeron
cuántos chicos que tenían que ser fuerte
el hombre de la casa
a su mujer etcétera a cuantos
pero también son
porque estas frases son muy comunes y
son
y la básica
porque pregunto esto
quizá estamos acostumbradas escucharlas
pero son frases violentas que
poco a poco el sexismo en nuestra
educación
son frases muy violentas que van
asignando a según lo femenino lo
masculino
ciertas características como debería ser
cada una
bueno
para entender un poquito más de esta
problemática
y algo que tampoco sé
la educación no solo
[Música]
raza o clase al que me refiero con esto
que discrimina los estudiantes más
pobres discrimina a las mujeres
discrimina a los estudiantes que son de
etnias originarias
a los estudiantes pertenecientes a la
comunidad lgtb
principalmente y porque como nosotros
permitimos que suceda esto como nosotros
permitimos que este sistema educativo se
agregue tan arbitrariamente a tantos
estudiantes bueno principalmente al no
tener un currículum de género con
enfoque de género
que esté comprometido con abordar estas
temáticas al no tener por ejemplo en los
colegios obligatoriamente educación
cívica educación sexual etcétera al
existir colegios particulares con
proyecto educativo que impongan alguna
manera de pensar y un montón de forma de
que hacen que nuestro sistema educativo
se agregue de esta manera a bueno y
también al no garantizar el acceso a la
educación a todos y todas de la misma
manera esto se manifiesta en la sociedad
de muchas maneras me gustaría dar todos
ejemplos que para mí son ejemplos muy
diferentes pero demuestran claramente
cómo se manifiesta el sexismo y la
educación acá se pueden ver tres actores
principales el estudiante la familia y
el entorno educativo
el primer ejemplo fue hace un par de
años en la comuna de los ángeles que
queda muy cerca de acá donde un colegio
particular subvencionado se fue a paro
algo increíble con colegio particular
subvencionado se movilicen
por diferentes problemáticas internas
está bien
una de esas demandas internas era que a
las mujeres en periodo de invierno sobre
todo se les dejara ir con pantalón es
algo muy básico y estudió en un colegio
municipal y eso es completamente normal
que pasó la directora se negó
rotundamente la directora ojo se negó
rotundamente a esta medida porque dijo
literalmente porque los hombres le van a
mirar el trasero a sus compañeras
o sea la misma directora estaba hablando
la violencia de género está negando que
sus alumnos puedan ir
y no se enfermen
está asumiendo que por naturaleza los
hombres solo quieren
solo quieren ver el cuerpo femenino sin
ninguna
sin ningún como tampoco personal o sea
como que es muy instintivo de los
hombres que no tienen control de su
mismo cuerpo
eso es violencia de género rotunda otro
ejemplo que más terrible y que para mí
el peor ejemplo que se puede dar cuando
me lo contaron me puse a llorar de eso
qué tiene que ver con
con una chica trans esto fue en santiago
igual a su parte un año atrás
una chica trans al no ser entendida por
sus padres hicieron esto bueno fue muy
inteligente sus padres lo metieron a un
colegio de puros hombres a una niña
qué pasó es bueno la niña tuvo depresión
le hicieron bullying estaba incómodo de
todas sus asignaturas fue verdaderamente
muy nefasto para ella fue una
experiencia traumática porque estaba
encasillado con puros hombres siendo que
yo era mujer
y bueno el tiempo fue pasando ella fue
creciendo fue cursando años y el colegio
fue adaptando medidas para poder tener
ese tipo para poder atender ese tipo de
situaciones que están invisibilizados
bueno que pasó llego a cuarto medio
licenciatura todos quieren licenciatura
yo estoy en cuarto medio y lo único que
quieren graduarme con mis compañeros
bueno esa niña quería algo parecido pero
tenía un valor agregado ella quería
licenciarse con jumper y condicionar al
colegio algo común en vez de usar
pantalones quería usar el jumper de
colegio el centro de alumnos acogió esto
esta petición la presentó al cuerpo
administrativo del establecimiento
y qué pasó afortunadamente y muy
sorprendentemente no le pusieron ninguna
traba
se hicieron todas las medidas le
compraron un jumper le cogieron la
insignia del colegio todo maravilloso
bueno llegó el día que pasó los padres
encerraron a su habitación en su
habitación a la niña negándole y
privándole su licenciatura que había
preparado con tanto esmero
acá se pueden ver los tres actores
principales todo lo que es el estudiante
en este caso de la chica trans que fue
completamente vulnerado sus derechos
el establecimiento que no estaba
preparado para acoger este tipo de
situaciones y los padres completamente
entró renovados y sexistas que
encerraron años su hija
encerraron a su hija por vergüenza
este ejemplo es horrible y es un claro
ejemplo de cómo nuestra sociedad está
tan marcada por un sistema machista y
patriarcal bueno
ahora quiero mostrar cómo se manifiesta
la sociedad el sexismo en la educación
qué es lo que nos gusta tanto a los
chilenos y no solo a los chilenos a
muchas personas la tele
podemos pasar horas y horas mirando tele
sea películas programas reality
así que una
y es un constante
[Música]
es una constante educación lo que
nosotros recibimos indirectamente de la
televisión
principalmente el cine
este es un estudio muy importante que se
realizó en eeuu donde dice que
menos
de los diálogos realizados en películas
son dichos por mujeres el 10 por ciento
de los castings que se realizan para
elegir personajes de una película tienen
equidad de género
el 29 por ciento de las mujeres que
trabajan el 29 por ciento solamente de
todas las películas tienen protagonistas
mujeres
y bueno a nosotros se nos enseña a hacer
sumisa a ser calmadas
a cuidar a los niños el hogar etcétera
traduce también en los medios de
comunicación
cuáles son las mayores profesiones que
se muestran en una mujer a la hora de
actuar en una película bueno lo típico
está principalmente las humanidades que
no tienen nada de malo pero por ejemplo
profesiones que inciden
sistemática
no son para nada tomando en cuenta la
mujer actualmente un 10 por ciento en
política
7 por ciento en leyes un 15 por ciento
en medicina y solamente un 3% en
deportes el deporte no tiene nada que
ver con las otras profesiones que
mencionen pero qué casualidad al hombre
son los que le enseñan a jugar a la
pelota a hacer deporte hace el fuerte
hábil etcétera solamente un 3 por ciento
de las mujeres que actúan en películas
tienen
o alguna profesión que tienen que ver
con el deporte y otra cosa en las
escenas grupales de las películas sobre
el 17% de este grupo de este colectivo
humano está compuesto por mujeres
bueno la publicidad de muchas empresas
por ejemplo ya
que se nos asocia a la limpieza o sea
las mujeres sólo estamos para limpiar
nuestro hogar que más perfume algo que
nosotros lo tenemos claro los perfumes
siempre siempre siempre
a la mujer y obviamente la sumisión
nosotros tenemos que servir a nuestra
pareja esposo padre e hijo etcétera para
eso estamos hechas para servir
pasemos a las cifras
el 46 de las noticias en prensa escrita
o televisión
no tienen enfoque de género o sea
repercuten
muestran estereotipos de género
increíblemente o sea todo lo que
mencioné anteriormente el 73% de los
altos cargos de el mundo mediático está
liderado por hombres sólo el 73 por
ciento supone que tenemos las mismas
capacidades porque solo
un gran porcentaje de lo que es el 73%
están los hombres
desde que las mujeres representamos la
mitad y aproximadamente la mitad de la
población mundial
estamos segregadas en un mismo espacio
sólo decimos un tercio de cada diálogo
de alguna película serio etcétera
y algo muy importante que tiene que ver
con la violencia en la por las redes
sociales la ciber violencia ha aumentado
ya y hasta el día de hoy afecta a más de
la mitad de las mujeres y sobre todo
niñas en nuestro país
si gano ahora pasemos a lo más feo en
delitos sexuales
de adultos el 90% son mujeres
tiene que ver con la trata de personas
el 94 7% son mujeres y eso que no
estamos contando a los niños
en el año 2000
[Música]
de los años 2008 al 2013 fueron 272 las
mujeres que murieron a manos de sus
parejas y exparejas
el 2014 fueron 40 los femicidios
consumados fueron 40 las mujeres que
murió
muy pocos pero en realidad es una cifra
alarmante
el 52.5 de estos casos tenían denuncias
anteriores
un porcentaje del 22,5 por ciento tenía
tenía medida cautelar o sea como puede
ser orden de alejamiento
algunas medidas de protección para la
mujer y a pesar de eso
más de ciento y me siguió frustrados
esto quiere decir que fueron intentos de
femicidio
pero aún así son crímenes de odio bueno
el 53.4 por ciento de estos crímenes
tenían también denuncia previa y
y el 2,7 por ciento de estos tenía
gordon de protección a las mujeres
bueno en el año 2016 45 fueron las
mujeres asesinadas por sus parejas y
exparejas como vemos a medida que vamos
pasando los años va incrementándose poco
a poco la cifra de los femicidios
un gran porcentaje de estos
denuncias previas y un parto
mediante
a su vez
el porcentaje también tenía
tenía denuncia esto quiere decir de que
las mujeres habían denunciado a sus
parejas a sus ex parejas a sus círculos
violentos pero lo único que se puede
hacer al respecto es proponer una orden
cautelar a pesar de tener una orden
cautelar
el 2017
hasta diciembre sólo estoy diciembre
fueron 40
entonces esto frustra
registró un femicidio y dos femicidio
pero solamente estos son
aún no tenemos vida
mujeres que mueren en poblaciones en
hospitales en muchas partes de nuestro
país y que no sé
el registro simplemente porque viven en
una
en un entorno muy violento y como es tan
violento no logra registrarse porque
digo esta cifra es tan alarmante tanto
y aunque pueden para algunos no
hoy día aquí en un año mueren más de 110
mujeres sólo por el hecho de ser mujeres
es terrible
este es un ejemplo claro de cómo el
sexismo afecta en la educación este es
un ejemplo claro de cómo los roles de
género que a pesar de que sean tan
normalizados
que todos los niños que salgan del
colegio van a ser violadores abusadores
etcétera pero pueden ser padres
violentos con sus hijos padres violentos
con sus madres pueden ser
y esposos que controlen el estado
financiero de su mujer que controle sus
salidas que controlen su teléfono
etcétera la violencia existe no
solamente de lo físico existe la
manipulación existe
un montón de maneras donde los hombres
hoy día violentan a las mujeres
bueno qué pasa con todo esto y que cuál
es nuestra tarea como jóvenes
principalmente nosotros los jóvenes y
los niños principalmente somos la
estructura base de la sociedad cambiando
una estructura base nosotros tenemos la
posibilidad de cambiar la sociedad a qué
me refiero con esto si cambiamos la
educación y le ponemos un currículum con
enfoque de género que esté dispuesto a
abordar estas temáticas de desigualdad
social no solamente en la educación sino
en la salud en el sistema de prevención
en el sistema de pensiones por ejemplo
cambiando esto la brecha de desigualdad
se va costando poquito a poquito hoy día
nosotros quizás sabemos más sobre lo que
es el feminismo pero en los colegios nos
enseñan porque tenemos un movimiento
social tan amplio como el movimiento
feminista donde se vio registrado el 8
de marzo pasado donde
a la calle a exigir violencia de género
cómo es posible eso sí que es un
movimiento social tan amplio porque no
se traduce en políticas públicas porque
no se traduce en leyes que cobijen a las
mujeres porque no se traduce en mejora
en los derechos humanos lo que tiene que
ver con la política de dignidad
porque no sucede eso es en nuestra tarea
si se mantiene el sexismo en la
educación no cambia la sociedad en
nuestra tarea estar en la base de la
sociedad cambiar toda la estructura para
20 años más nuestra sociedad sea más
equitativa sea más justa sea más digna
porque por ejemplo yo quiero tener hijos
y no quiero que mi hija salga a una
fiesta y le pase algo no quiero que mi
hija pueda salir sin miedo a que no
vuelva a la casa no quiero que mi hija
la culpen si le pasa algo por su falda o
porque había tomado porque el problema
amigos míos no es la falda no es el
trago no son los celos un celo no
justifica
a nuestro país y lo hace tenemos que
cambiar porque si no cambiamos nosotros
vamos a seguir incrementando la cifra de
femicidio no sólo en nuestro país sino
también a nivel mundial
que una cifra alarmante el llamado a
todos los directores y directores de
colegios a hacer políticas de género
tener secretarías de género en cada
centro de estudiantes incidir en los
espacios queramos o no tenemos que
incidir en los espacios para cambiar que
podemos participar en organizaciones
políticas sociales etcétera pero tenemos
que cambiar también a nosotros mismos
en nuestro colegio nuestra junta de
vecinos nuestras poblaciones donde la
gente más vulnerable está ahí y no tiene
acceso a esta información si nosotros
cambiamos la educación si cambiamos la
educación cambiamos la sociedad
como dije no hay transformación si se
mantiene el sexismo en la educación es
el mensaje que les dejo muchas gracias
[Música]
y